jean eric branaa historien et
spécialiste des états unis bonjour jean
eric branaa merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin tous les regards
sont donc tournés vers genève ce matin
joe biden qui rencontre vladimir poutine
concrètement que faut-il attendre de ce
sommet il faut attendre d'amour ce qu'on
a sous les yeux c'est à dire qu'il ya
une rencontre est en réalité quand les
relations sont aussi bas qu elles
peuvent être aujourd'hui en fait d'une
pays de chaque côté on dit que ça fait
30 ans que ça n'a pas été aussi
catastrophique
le fait de se parler et déjà une bonne
chose c'est la stratégie que du ride
d'avenir d'avant et qu'il est devenu
président il avait beaucoup développée
pendant sa campagne
n'oublions pas que c'est un diplomate et
il considère que la diplomatie c'est
parler avec les gens qui sont le plus
éloignés de nous donc là on ou
difficilement faire plus éloignées
peut-être avec la chine mais ce sera
l'étape suivante
alors on fait que à l'origine de cette
invitation de cette rencontre c'est un
job hayden quelles sont vraiment les
motifs les objectifs du président
américain
ils sont nombreux je veux dire c'est
d'abord de se parler donc de calmer les
tensions qu'il peut y avoir dans le
bourg de dans le but de stabiliser les
relations entre les états unis et la
chine ne fait que ça ne sombrent à spa
et c'est vrai dans les relations
difficiles c'est assez facile que ça
s'embrase et puis surtout on a derrière
en arrière-plan la chine qui apparaît
puisque c'est là le vrai but de joe
biden il s'agit de faire en sorte que
les russes ne se sentent pas totalement
rejetée par la communauté internationale
surtout que vaille de dia de faire un
vrai numéro au g7 et à l'otan en
réunissant le blog diplomatie comme il
vient de le dire donc de ne pas renvoyer
par effet contraire les russes dans les
bras des chinois donc on ouvre une porte
et on verra ce que donnera cette porte à
la fin cette porte ouverte mais en
réalité c'est de pouvoir montrer qu'il
ya quand même une possibilité de se
raccrocher ne se rapprocher sur certains
dossiers sensibles difficile alors on a
quand même l'impression que le
scepticisme est de mise en tout cas du
côté américain on sait que la maison
blanche a lancé un message qui est
plutôt clair si vous attendez des
retombées concrètes de ce sommet vous
pouvez attendre longtemps
comment est-ce qu'il faut justement
interprété cet avertissement au madère
alors je crois que le scepticisme est
fort des deux côtés en réalité on vient
de le dire ça fait 30 ans que les
relations sont difficiles entre la
russie et les etats unis elle était
encore plus difficile avant 20 ans ou où
c'était l'union soviétique et qu'il y
avait une guerre froide pour autant moi
je me méfierais quand même cette
déclaration dans lequel on dit qu'il
faut rien nada temps parce qu'il a quand
même des sujets sur lesquels les deux
hommes peuvent se rapprocher en
particulier la protection des
populations en syrie sur lesquels ils
donnent compte beaucoup quand même sur
poutine et puis le climat qui parle de
la vraie grande question du mandat joe
biden et et la fixer de nouveaux
objectifs c'était le 22 avril au moment
du sommet de la terre aux états unis à
ce moment-là poutine avait répondu par
l'affirmative en disant qu'il allait lui
aussi baissé les gaz à effet de serre
dans son pays de façon drastique la
dessus je pense qu'on pourrait attendre
qu'il sorte quelque chose de ceux de
cette rencontre ce qui voudrait dire
qu'on sortirait avec un bilan positif
même si sur le reste c'est vrai que ça
va être très difficile de faire bouger
les lignes en une seule fois
d'ailleurs encore une fois c'est une
dialogue renoué c'est ce qu'on va
retenir
à votre avis la balle est dans quel camp
ce matin j'ai envie de vous dire que la
valette au centre halles c'est clair on
commence un nouveau match il s'agit de
tourner la page train pl dans laquelle
les états unis et là je parle du
personnel politique américain était très
inquiet que les intérêts américains ne
soient pas défendu auprès de poutine
quand il ya eu cette rencontre en 2017
en particulier
plus globalement on sait qu'avec jo
maiden c'est la fermeté qu'il n'y a
aucune
il n'y aura pas de transit jans
vis-à-vis de poutine mais en même temps
c'est vrai que comme je le disais la
porte est ouverte alors le rapport de
force entre les données elles mêmes si
c'était là plutôt porter votre question
les états unis sont évidemment bien plus
en avance sur un grand nombre de plans
qu'ils soient militaires stratégiques
économiques et mais en même temps la
capacité de nuire des russes est très
fort des virus effectivement ne n'ont
pas la même force que les états unis sur
un certain nombre de dossiers qu'ils
soient stratégiques militaires
économiques
et puis il ya des incompréhensions de
part et d'autre notamment sur cette
question des droits de l'homme si chère
à dubaï danny lee a dévoué sa vie et
c'est vrai que sa vision n'est vraiment
pas celle de poutine lors c'est là
dessus aussi que ça risque d'accrocher
pas mal et là dessus on peut pas
attendre aujourd'hui des avancées mais
par contre bayonne va être très ferme
cette question et là il s'adressera à la
fois à ses convictions mais également à
son électorat électorat américain de
façon plus générale parce que c'est une
question qui compte beaucoup dans ce
pays et justement comment cette
rencontre est elle perçue aux états unis
pays que vous connaissez bien
allez encore une fois il le fait que ce
soit biden rassure plutôt tout le monde
parce que mme hayden a toujours été
ferme vis-à-vis de poutine a rappelé
dans le reportage qui l'a traité de
tueur au début de son mandat
mais en 2011 il avait déjà regarder dans
le blanc des yeux comme il dit lui même
en lui disant je vois que vous n'avez
pas d'amis
autrement dit vous êtes le diable au
rail on était encore plus haut dans la
rhétorique agressive si on peut le dire
ainsi mais ça montre aussi que que
brydon porte une certaine autonomie
vis-à-vis de la russie qui portent de
par son âge il a traversé la guerre
froide il a donc les mêmes idées que les
amériques de
son âge qui ont toujours vu les russes
comme l'ennemi et c'est vrai que cette
complexité qui lie à entre les deux pays
bas et donne l'incarnent totalement donc
aucune crainte dans son pays vis-à-vis
de ce qui peut se passer entre tutti
n'est pas agent savent bien que leurs
intérêts seront défendus je parle encore
une fois vous hésitez alors il ya
énormément de points de divergence mais
y at il tout de même des points de
convergence entre les deux grandes
puissances mondiales
oui les bois de l'argent ce sont son
four membres eux c'est vrai le climat
est certainement comme je dis d'ailleurs
le point de convergence le plus évident
on va aussi beaucoup discuté des
questions de cyber qu'elle soit
cybersécurité ou au cyberespace
là-dessus peut-être qu'il faut les
points de vue pourraient se rapprocher
alors c'est vrai que les américains
accusent beaucoup les russes d'ingérence
notamment et lait et d'oeufs et de
hacking mai mais comme les russes voit
la balle en expliquant qu'ils ne sont
pour rien et qui sont eux aussi victimes
peut-être que la question de la sécurité
cyber pourrait arriver à trouver une fin
plus heureuse on va dire en tout cas une
voix de travail qui pourrait être
intéressante car pour l'instant on sait
qu'il n'y aura pas de conférence de
presse commune prévue après leurs
discussions
joe biden et vladimir poutine qui ont
préféré faire tout seul lors leur
conférence de presse justement comment
interpréter cette décision à jean-eric
cabral a écouté la conférence de presse
commune c'est quand tout va bien en
réalité rien n'est les biens entre les
deux pays et est rien n'allait dans la
conférence de presse qui avait été
donnée par conjointement par donald
trump et l'admirent poutine par exemple
a dit m poutine avait parlé en premier
aux états unis on s'était demandé
pourquoi donc la préséance le protocole
mais il n'y a pas vraiment de raison
ensuite le la rencontre s'était fait
dans le secret le plus absolu et poutine
avait commenté cette rencontre en
expliquant que tout s'était très bien
passé qu'il était très content des
résultats
le fantasme s'était aussitôt envolés
bien entendu quelles étaient ses
résultats pourquoi qu'est ce qui avait
été discuté on n'en savait rien et est
annoncée toujours et aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs donc là dessus bien sûr
l'hostilité naturel des américains
vis-à-vis des russes avaient enflammé
les imaginations et a fait que beaucoup
d'erreurs ont été commises par
l'administration trotte dans cette
rencontre qui aurait dû être prises avec
des pincettes
et effectivement quand il a terminé en
mettant que ses propres services de
renseignement pour donner crédit à la
parole de celui qui est vécu comme
l'ennemi d'amérique
bien évidemment c'était la cerise sur le
gâteau et la classe politique américaine
c'était là aussi enflammé d'ailleurs
quelques mois plus tard le congrès
quelques mois quelques semaines plus
tard le congrès a voté des nouvelles
sanctions à l'unanimité contre l'avis de
donald trump qui avait menacé de
s'enlever toulouse qui finalement ne
l'avait pas posée puisque le congrès
était unanime contre lui est donc levé
tôt outre été surmontée mais là dessus
on n'aura pas la même chose avec du
rider on aura avancé dossier par dossier
de façon pragmatique on va discuter de
dossiers urgents comme le lui star iii
qui devraient être prolongées jusqu'à
2020 6 on va discuter de la question des
populations en syrie on va discuter
merkel distante discuter l'iran d'israël
de la crimée de navalni et les dossiers
seront abordés
un parent et chacun va faire un bar de
son point de vue ça sera déjà une
première étape
c'est ce qu'on appelle se reparler elle
a un programme bien chargé des
discussions qui risque d'être longue en
tout cas merci beaucoup jean eric branaa
d'avoir été avec nous pour décrypter ce
matin ce sommet très attendu entre
vladimir poutine et joe biden
eric branaa spécialiste des états unis
merci